Australia trades its tourism reputation
on images like this the 1500 mile long
Great Barrier Reef is not only home to
teeming marine life it is itself a
living structure of coral it also has an
uncomfortable neighbor Queensland's coal
industry coal accounts for about one in
every five dollars directly and
indirectly in the Queensland economy and
directly and indirectly about 300,000
jobs that is set to grow as the vast
galilee coal basin to the west is
exploited and the coal ports expanded
Abbot Point will soon be dredged and
developed into the world's largest coal
terminal 3 million tons of dredge spoil
will be dumped in the marine park
shipping traffic is forecast to triple
by 2030 just short of levels seen in the
Panama Canal the development hasn't
escaped the attention of the United
Nations which will consider in June
whether to list this UNESCO World
Heritage Site as being in danger we're
running a huge risk we have the
international community concern UNESCO
extremely concerned you know we're
talking about millions of cubic meters
of dredged spoil being dumped in a
fragile pristine environment and we're
talking about increased shipping
shipping is closely regulated in the
Marine Park the Resources Council says
there's only been one safety incident in
ten years it also points to a government
study which found most of the damage to
the reef has been from extreme weather
events and an infestation of crown of
thorns starfish there are non-government
organizations who are lobbying the World
Heritage Committee to declare the Great
Barrier Reef is in danger but we need to
understand their motivations what they
are trying to do is shut down the coal
and gas export industries of Queensland
and they will say anything and do
anything to achieve that goal
Queensland coal industry has every
reason to feel paranoid
your vessel it's been the target of
Greenpeace and its trademark eye
catching campaigns
however the conduct of expanding
resources companies is also attracting
the attention of fund managers well I
think the issue around shipping in the
Barrier Reef is associated with a
broader environmental and social
governance issues which is shaping some
of the important investment decisions in
Queensland from a an investor's
perspective those developments raised a
number of questions about how those
companies are managing what potential
future risks might be with any
development there are risks in this case
however it's being balanced with the
future of the greatest living organism
on earth all Alan Bloomberg